[Music]
in 2019 fans rejoiced when the elite
battle ranger film finally brought the
beloved manga to the big screen
after languishing in development hell
for years and years unfortunately the
movie underperformed at the u.s box
office and as a result
the nation franchise's future has been
up in the air a leader battle angel is
by no means a bad film
it's not bad or good
that part's up to you though
professional critics gave it rather
mixed reviews
audiences have rated it extremely well
and there's some pretty
major talent involved the movie was
directed by sin city and from dusk till
dawn helmsman robert rodriguez
and was almost directed by james cameron
himself but cass was about as stellar as
any movie he could hope to have
rosa salazar anchored the movie as an
uncannily wide-eyed titular cyborg
warrior
and her surrogate father and mentor dr
ido was played by two-time academy award
winner christoph
volts jennifer connolly and mahershala
ali brought a couple more oscars into
the mix to sharing and the antagonist
vector
and many of the other roles were played
by reliable genre actors like ed skrein
and jackie l haley still at the end of
the day elite battle angel failed to
live up to its financial expectations
and usually that would be the end of the
ip's big budget hollywood travels
at least unless something dramatic
happens well it looks like something
dramatic just happened
everyone's favorite big-eyed cyborg lady
might still have some surprises up her
sleeve because it looks like a lita
battle angel is heading back to theaters
thank you for saving me
as september 2020 started turning into
october a group of elite
battle angel devotees calling themselves
the elite army were preparing for a
mission
in a message spreading on twitter
members of the fan fiction were urged to
start an elite themed twitter campaign
with the intention to get cinemark to
re-release the movie in its cinemas
one fan posted a set of directions to
coordinate the campaign
along with the message alitarami please
share this flyer far and wide we need
all hands the trending event will go
down on october 1st
7 a.m pacific standard time 11 a.m
coordinated universal time the
re-release elite hashtag went live as
planned
and to say it was a success is an
understatement after mere hours senamax
twitter acknowledged the campaign
and gave the fans some extremely welcome
news announcing
hey elite army we hear you loud and
clear stay tuned
more info coming soon hashtag re-release
alita
in a reply to an alita fans thank you
message they also wrote that they quote
loved the dedication the campaign had
shown while cinemark has yet to give
specifics it certainly looks like the
sci-fi epic is set to make a comeback
and select theaters
vocal movie fans have been in the news
lately thanks to justice league's much
mythologized snyder cuts
which is coming to hbo max in 2021 after
years of fans campaigning
elite battle angel may have only come
out in 2019 but has also been gearing up
for a second life for quite a while
though in this case everyone seems to
think the original movie is awesome
and is focusing their campaign on
clamoring for a sequel in late 2019
fans collected over 120 000 signatures
in their petition for a sequel
and the movie's producer john landau
advised them to keep at it the elite
army has done just that
and they've advocated heavily for the
movie and it's possible sequel
the people behind the lead to battle
angel certainly believed in its
longevity as they included a number of
neat cameos a sequel bait
a briefly seen character called gelder
from elita's past is played by none
other than michelle rodriguez
jay courtney pops up in a blink and you
miss it moment as a prominent future
antagonist
the mighty motable champ jashugan that
character is important in later stories
oh well there's a matter of hollywood
legend edward norton who appears in the
film's cliffhanger
as the evil genius mastermind nova it's
possible that the filmmakers and the
fans have been right to hold out hope
because some think a little battle
language or two might already be in the
works
in july 2020 courtney's instagram
account posted a photo of him decked out
on a motion capture rig
and the caption read trying out my new
rollerblades could it be a reference to
his impending return as jashugan
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one